they'll be taking on that man right
there the southpaw
cole irvin coming off a sparkler of a
performance last time out against the
detroit tigers kype
six innings and this is the number for
me zero walks
six strikeouts and he does and he gets a
huge strikeout
perfect pitch you said it absolutely
perfect look at the location down and
away
probably looks like a strike the entire
time out of the hand
of cole irvin get a couple fastballs up
you think you got to protect
crowd this lefty
and he did and that's a good fastball so
irvin makes a good pitch to get stewart
and the orioles strand the pair in the
bottom of the first
lopez has nobody to blame but himself
right now for this jam two walks in a
wild pitch
and runners are at second and third and
nobody out
hit hard right side backhanded throw to
first and
that should get a run home and it does
so the a's lead one nothing on the rbi
ground out by seth brown
touch it with two as they say put it in
play
and biscotti does drops a base hit into
left field that will bring home murphy
and it's two to nothing nie's lead so a
nice job of hitting by piscotti as he
had to stay back and would look like a
breaking ball
just leap right into the netting that's
right and there's an off speed pitch and
it's a strikeout
so severino goes down swinging cole
irvin's starting to feel it a little
bit you know what i mean gets the wiggle
from murph back there
four fingers shake him up pull that
string lefty
severino fish are biting kite
and a high fastball quick work for cole
irvine couple of
easy ground balls and a strikeout
irvin's been good so far two-nothing a's
nicole irvin has been pretty tough so
far
yeah the leadoff hit by mullins the only
hit in the game for the orioles
and there's an infield hit for michael
franco
andres went a long way just to get a
glove on it but no chance to make a play
about the curveball we thought pats
almost hit one of those
out that's the pitch that probably more
hittable
even though the numbers don't show it
coming in he hadn't only thrown what
about
five or four or five of them dj stewart
struck out
is only at bat back in the first inning
very short lead actually went back to
the base bounce down to first
to second for one yeah nobody there
safe yeah irwin bourbon doesn't get
there in time or otherwise it's going to
be a double play ball
he had to double he double pumped about
two or three times waiting for him you
can see olson who's so good that he's
going to get back to the bag and
he's not there and this is chapman
gets the ball and he's got a rifle arm
he just
throws it and almost throws it by
gets mount castle to play to obama's two
strikes
steward at first here's a line drive
base hit
into center field stewart around second
he'll hold up right oh it gets away from
l'oreal stewart advances so does mount
castle
and the orioles have the tying runs in
scoring position nice play coverage
right there that's
that's the change up so he does cover
the outside corner coriano just runs
right by it always want to stay below
the hop even if you're an outfielder
did he go yes he did
so a big strikeout is severino strikes
out for the second time
five k's for cole irvin
loriano drives one left center field
and that baby's gone second home run of
the year for ramon laureato and it was
another hanger
would you spin a little bender up there
for me let me get on top
and he does speaking of that warehouse
out and right kype
pack your bags all aboard next stop
pound town pedro severino struck out
both at bats against irving in this game
and the orioles have them loaded with
nobody down three straight hits
ripped base hit left field
mount castle hustles home for mancini
and the orioles are on the board 3-1
well there's the rbi you were talking
about
finally could have been hit so hard that
trey doesn't want to get doubled up so
he has to go back
to tag up and what happens is you only
get one
so five and a third for urban those 93
pitches
a walk and a strikeout and here's your
samara petite he just got dropped into
the middle of
a tough situation freddie galvez on the
first pitch pops it up
that is huge because freddie galvez is a
tough out
so here's ramon urrias
bounce to short and that'll do it how
about you sparrow petite
that's what he's all about there are two
outs here in the bottom of the eighth
inning
so the hitter is freddie galvez
he's over three in the ball game
and there's a liner and chapman reaches
out makes the catch
and that will do it for the orioles in
the eighth inning
so bottom of the ninth inning diekman
has
one save this year
deekman's got one trevino's got a couple
he'll face righty lefty righty here
jake deepman right he's hitting 111
against the southpaw lefties 385.
here's aureus marias is old for three
couple of groundouts and a pop
out and he stayed with the fastball why
not no
chance for reyes he swung in a couple
pitches well out of the strike zone
and he was over match i couldn't agree
more and i think
flailing might be an accurate descriptor
of
what those last two swings look like
so the only right-handed hitter they
have on the bench is ryan mckenna who's
a rookie
so it's about that decision do you want
to match up offensively
do you want to match up with your
bullpen arms
mullins pops it up and that is out
number two
hayes is all for four with two
strikeouts
hustling in he's gonna get there and
he's got it
and that's the ball game so just a very
tightly played ball game tonight another
very solid performance dallas by the
athletics and they have won
12 consecutive games
they've got another outstanding
performance from the man in the rotation
cole irvin the offense stepped up and
got knocks when they needed to
big blast from ramon loriano early in
the ball game
and it really does feel like the a's are
hanging 10 maybe 12
really riding the wave